thanks for calling on my hiking new
books i can help you
for mahogany books in southeast
washington d.c
this is what business unusual looks like
orders taken by phone yes ma'am books
sanitized before being hand-delivered to
customers parked out front
derrick and raimondi young quit their
full-time jobs years ago to pursue their
dream
creating mahogany books a home for
readers seeking literature
on the african american experience the
biggest premise was how do we make
black books accessible no matter where
you live i'm from oklahoma proud to be
from oklahoma but i didn't have
that type of access to black books when
they founded mahogany books 13 years ago
it was an
online bookstore nearly three years ago
they opened this
their brick and mortar business the
young say that it quickly grew to
account for 75 percent of their revenue
then coronavirus hit everything had
stopped and we had to shut our doors it
was a little scary in the very beginning
because this was our bread and butter
african-american small business owners
have been disproportionately affected by
the pandemic
because the youngs had already built
their online business they didn't have
to shut down entirely
but nationwide from february to april of
this year the number of
active african-american small business
owners dropped 41 percent
compared to 22 percent of all active
small business owners
we have to be wise we still have to look
at funding that comes in different areas
because now with doors closed
less traffic is coming in our space when
the federal paycheck protection program
or ppp
passed as part of the cares act in late
march the motion
is adopted the youngs applied to the
program through their bank
before i was able to figure it out the
first allotment of money
had already run out it takes a little
bit more for
i think genuinely small businesses to
figure out how to navigate some of these
things because
that's not necessarily what our
wheelhouse is the young's experienced
this like many other african-american
small businesses trying to take
advantage of ppp
knowing the history of financial
exclusion means that we have a program
that was already
not going to work to the best advantage
of business owned by people of color
ashley harrington is a policy expert at
the center for responsible lending
a non-profit consumer advocacy group so
these programs go through the sba the
small business administration
they go through the sba um but the
intermediary is a financial institution
has this posed challenges to
african-american businesses
more so than business owners at large it
absolutely has right so anytime we have
a program that relies so heavily on
traditional financial institutions we're
automatically going to have a problem
for businesses owned by people of color
particularly businesses owned
by black people to get access to the
funds because they have
a different type of relationship with
mainstream finance institutions in other
communities
they have typically not been served well
by the financial mainstream
the sba says it and the treasury
department value all lenders and are
actively engaged in outreach to
community development financial
institutions and minority depository
institutions
cdfis and mdis it says have
traditionally excelled in providing
financial assistance to minority
communities and
underserved populations the young say
that when they launched their business
they didn't rely on the banking system
we didn't go to banks
and get approved for loans we had to
bootstrap it ourselves and
and pull out of our 401ks that we had
when we were working and
and go to friends so when the youngs
didn't hear back about their ppp
application and they still haven't it's
been weeks
they embraced the same entrepreneurial
spirit that they had when they first
opened their business
they moved in-person author talks to
virtual sessions
to have a conversation about where black
america is they participated in dc's
curbside pickup pilot program
and they created book bundles for
parents homeschooling
and now following the killing of george
floyd the young say there's been a
growing demand for their books
they say they've seen a 400 increase in
online sales over the previous year
since closing their store to customers
the young say revenue has dropped
only 10 percent even though online has
been rocking and rolling we don't know
how long this new
space this new era is going to be here
right so even though today
it's great i'm assuming that after a
while the online will kind of drop off
and so that's what we're looking at with
grants and different funding in that way
to help bridge the gap and support their
three part-time employees they also
applied for and were granted an economic
injury disaster loan
or eidl through the small business
administration
e-idls of up to ten thousand dollars
were designed the sba says
to provide economic relief to businesses
that are currently experiencing a
temporary loss of revenue
they don't have to be repaid so we can
have it shipped out with the other book
know your value they know part of their
value to the community is in their
curation
our logo is our daughter reading a book
and helping parents pass on their
heritage to their children
having the online space be there has
been the lifesaver for us because people
can still
shop people can still get the resources
they need at home as they're
homeschooling their kids
especially if they're looking at
culturally sensitive and culturally
aware books and resources
they now have a spot that they can still
do that no matter where they live
experts say the net effect of
black-owned small businesses facing
disproportionate challenges could
persist well beyond the kovid pandemic
so could what we've been discussing
today have an impact on
the wealth disparity in america
absolutely
important to remember is that business
ownership was uh wasn't had an
incredible impact on wealth creation
right business owners of color had had
were like more likely to have
a lot more wealth than than people of
color who don't own businesses
so business ownership is definitely one
way
to help people of color build wealth and
get on the track to close in the wealth
gap and so when we have a situation
like this where they can't get access to
a critical lifeline that will help them
stay afloat and stay open
they are definitely losing wealth and
that has a ripple effect in their entire
community
the youngs may be doing better than
other minority businesses in their
community right now
perhaps because they're able to offer
something of intangible value
escape and knowledge at a time of
immense hardship
so the total is 1802 thank you for
supporting us as well
it means a lot yeah